-Our next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actress
you know from
films like "Booksmart"
and shows such as
"Unbelievable" and "Dopesick."
She stars in "Rosaline,"
which is streaming on
Hulu and Disney+ October 14th.
She also stars in
"Ticket to Paradise,"
which is in theaters
October 21st.
Let's take a look.
-Are you guys sure
you're good with this?
Because you know
you could just tell me.
You don't have to do
a whole Trojan Horse thing.
-What -- what -- what are you --
what are you --
-What? What's that?
-Hmm?
-Didn't you tell me
that story, Mom?
-No, I told you.
Trojan --
I told you that story.
That was me.
-It doesn't matter.
Doesn't matter.
We just are both here for you.
-Yeah, lockstep.
-Please welcome back to the show
Kaitlyn Dever, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-She's amazing.
-Welcome back, Kaitlyn.
-She's so cool.
-Isn't she great?
We're very lucky.
We're very lucky
to have her this week.
I'm wondering -- You've done
such wonderful work
in recent years in things
like "Unbelievable,"
in things like "Dopesick."
They're a little heavy.
-Little bit, yeah.
-And I'm wondering if
it's nice for you
to get to do something light,
like romantic comedy
or a Shakespearean
period comedy?
-Yes. You know, it really is.
I'm so fortunate to be able to
kind of jump around
between the two.
I've never been able to choose
between comedy or drama.
So, it's nice, because it is
still a challenge,
though, comedy.
And it does work a different
part of your brain in a way.
But I've had the best time
on these rom-coms.
It is really relaxing.
I feel relaxed.
-I would imagine.
I guess it could
break either way.
Is it very relaxing to be
doing a scene with
George Clooney
and Julia Roberts,
who maybe
do it better than anyone,
especially in the genre,
or is it the stress
of knowing that
you're doing it with two of
the people that
are the best of the genre?
-It does -- You know, I thought
it would kind of level out,
and then it kind of
just goes up and down,
that, like, nervousness
and fear like, "Oh, my God.
I'm in a movie with
George Clooney
and Julia Roberts."
And then it kind of
chills out again.
But they -- The two of them
are just the best.
I mean, they really --
Their friendship,
being around that kind of energy
is just really so sweet.
-It's also great that --
I mean, again,
you play their daughter
in this film,
so you're allowed to walk around
the rest of your life and say,
"I know what you're thinking.
Did George Clooney and
Julia Roberts have a baby?"
-Listen, it's true.
-Yeah.
-I got to do that.
-It's true.
-There are some really wonderful
outtakes at end of the film
that make it clear that you got
to ad lib, as well.
-Yeah.
-I can't imagine what the energy
of that would be like.
-I mean, the energy on the set
was so much fun.
I can't even tell you.
George and Julia were
goofing around all the time.
They love making
each other laugh.
They love making everyone around
on set laugh, me laugh.
It was hard to keep a
straight face most of the time.
And it was funny.
I really think about,
like, how I just normalized
taking a speedboat
to work every day.
-Yeah. We should note,
on top of everything else,
you are shooting on an island.
-Right.
-So I guess you're --
Ultimately, you'll do movies.
You're willing to
make sacrifices.
You'll work on an island.
-Right, exactly. Exactly.
-You'll commute on a speedboat
and you'll work with
George Clooney
and Julia Roberts.
-I guess.
-You'll do all those things.
-Yeah.
-For your art.
-Right. It's for the art.
It's for the craft.
-Now, you also --
We mentioned you're --
So, this is a very --
a novel idea for a film.
So, you are Rosaline,
who is Romeo's, basically, ex.
-Yep. I was there first.
-Nobody thinks about
what happened to
Romeo's ex before he met Juliet.
Like, his life started then.
But we all know.
-We all know.
-Yeah.
It's such a cool idea, right?
It was something I read,
actually,
when I was like 15, this script.
And Rosaline is mentioned in
the original story,
"Romeo and Juliet," but we don't
know much about her.
We don't get to
discover that much.
So it was really cool
to be able to, like, dive in
and kind of --
With this thing, I mean,
it was modernized dialogue.
It was super-funny.
But you can really kind of do
anything and everything
with this kind of role.
So it was a lot of fun.
-Do you feel -- Did you feel at
all constrained by the costumes
or do you feel like it
brought you alive?
-You know, well, we were
shooting in the middle of Italy
and in Rome and a
couple places outside of Rome --
-You have so -- I'm so glad
things are going like
this for you.
[ Laughter ]
Like, just --
-I was in Tuscany.
-Because I do want to stress,
"Dopesick" was one of
my favorite things last year.
If you saw you in "Dopesick,"
you would never think
that you were going to be
in Italy,
you were going to be
on a beautiful island,
so I'm very happy
this has all happened for you.
-Thank you. No, I'm so lucky.
This movie
was really fun to make.
But, yeah, those costumes
were -- I was wearing, like --
My wig was like 15 pounds,
and it was really hot.
And my costumes
basically felt like
I was just wearing a floor rug.
But our costume designer
is a genius,
and these costumes
were absolutely beautiful,
every single one of them.
But, yeah, it was hot.
It was hot.
-Did I read this correctly,
that you used your time in Italy
to learn how to drive a manual?
-Yeah, well, that's a
really strong statement,
because I don't think
I really succeeded there,
because --
-To even take it on
is pretty intense.
-Well, they gave me
a rental car.
I got a rental car, and it just
happened to be a stick shift.
And I was like, "I can do this."
My mom knows how to drive.
And her whole thing was,
"Clutch, gas.
Clutch, gas."
-Yeah.
-She was just doing this
in the lesson the whole time.
And I was like, "What is that?"
-Yeah.
That's what my dad did, as well.
And I wanted to say,
"To begin with,
you don't use your hands,
so stop."
-Right. Yeah.
And there's three of them
down there.
I can't do it.
But I decided, you know,
my sister -- My mom left us.
And my sister and I wanted to go
up into this, like, really cool,
like, town that had been there
since like the 12th century.
-Did she leave you
because of how mean you were
about the clutch-gas thing or...
-No, she went on an Italian
adventure with my dad.
-Alright. Very nice.
-Yes.
But I decided to take
this little trip.
And I think I got --
I was like, "I got this."
And there was a nice -- Like,
right before we got up this,
like, tiny, tiny hill --
It was, like, tiny.
But, like, there was, like,
this nice parking lot.
We could have stopped there.
And I was like, "Let's just get
where we're going.
Let's just do that."
And I literally --
Like, our car --
I was not in the right gear.
It was so bad.
I was, like, rolling
backwards down the hill.
It was the scariest thing.
I'm just with my sister.
My sister and I never fight.
I was screaming at her.
I was furious.
And she did nothing wrong,
but I was
blaming everything on her.
-Well, based on
my experiences in Italy,
they're super-chill
when American tourists
are rolling backwards
down a hill.
They definitely
keep it to themselves
and don't talk with their hands.
-Yep. There's suddenly
children at play everywhere.
All of the sudden.
I was stressed out.
It was so bad.
-That is lovely to hear you that
you and your sister don't fight.
You guys also collaborate.
-We do.
-You write and perform
music together.
Is that something you have done
since you were super-young?
-I mean, we've always
loved making music together.
I think we started writing --
actually taking it
seriously and writing together
probably when I was like 19, 20.
And then we started
taking it even more seriously.
And we are now
coming out with an E.P.
-Very exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
We've released
a couple of singles.
Like, we released, like, one of
our first singles pre-pandemic,
and now we're ready to
release some stuff.
-Do you have a band name?
Do you consider
yourselves a band?
I know it's the two of you.
-Yes, we are a band.
It is the two of us.
And for longest time,
we've had a name
for our band,
but no one can pronounce it.
No one can say it.
-What was it before?
-It was -- Okay, so,
formerly known as Beulahbelle.
-Okay, Beulahbelle.
-And now we're just Devers.
-Okay, so you,
like, messed around,
you looked around,
and you're like,
"We're just going to use
our last name."
-"We're just gonna
just go straight to the basics,
just get back to it,"
you know?
It makes more sense.
-Do you collaborate well
when you are being creative
when you write songs together?
Do you feel like somebody has
to take the lead or do you --
-You know,
it's actually really cool.
I've -- We've actually
gotten to know each other
in a really --
Like, we've gotten to know
more about each other
through the writing process.
I used to be, like --
We used to be, like,
afraid to show each other
the songs we've written,
and now it's,
like, a really cool,
collaborative process
that I get to do with her,
which is really special.
-And true story that you
recorded with Phoebe Bridgers?
-True story.
-That's amazing.
-Yes. Our producer is --
-She's wonderful.
-Yeah, she works with the same
producer that we use.
And he called us up one day
and he was like,
"You want to sing on a
Phoebe Bridgers Christmas song?"
So we sang, like,
"Silent Night,"
and just randomly --
It was the best.
It was so cool.
-That's great.
Did they --
When she called and asked,
was she asking for Beulahbelle
and did you have to
break the news to her
that you were
no longer using that name?
-Basically.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But she still
went ahead with it,
which I think
speaks to your talents.
-Yes, yes, exactly.
-It's always
so lovely to have you here.
Congratulations on both films.
And thanks so much
for being here.
You guys...
-Thanks for having me.
-...that's Kaitlyn Dever.
"Rosaline" is streaming on
Hulu and Disney+ October 14th.
And "Ticket to Paradise"
is in theaters October 21st.
We'll be right back.